hallo mein name ist super und meine
basis der tür steht offen herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
auf seinem kanal und zwar das video
heute vier verschiedene themen
beinhalten und zwar luca reagiert auf
video
zunächst einmal werde ich auch ein paar
videos reagieren die immer wieder zu
gewalt habt also eher weiten flug zeigt
euch blog ausschnitte ihr vielleicht
wird die letzten fünf tage im urlaub und
ich allerdings nur im ersten und zweiten
tag ein blog hochgeladen weil wir sehr
sehr viele stalker erfahrungen leider
erleben mussten nämlich die frage danach
halt auch noch immer so ein bisschen was
gefehlt hatte die kamera immer dabei ich
wollte die blogs aber einfach nicht an
den tagen noch während ich im urlaub
beim hochladen und fans verfolgt haben
andere leute rausgefunden anhand der
glocken irgendwelchen himmelsrichtungen
und sterben wo wir wohnen und keine
ahnung war das einfach nicht so cool und
ich bin auch nicht so cool aber auf
jeden fall wieder video heißt so
aufgebaut sein dass ich als erstes auf
ein paar videos von fischer reagiere
dann beiden sich noch die wenigen blog
ausschnitte zeigen die ich jetzt nur
noch nicht hochgeladen habe und drittens
habe ich gerade vergessen 2000 jahre
später am ende werde ich euch noch mal
erklären
überhaupt gerade so los ist also warum
das mit dem luca schottland ist nicht
wirklich lieb und wo ich diesen tagen
bin weil ich bin in amerika und zwei
tagen aber wir fangen jetzt erst mal an
mit dem video
[Applaus]
sein dass wir mit vier wörtern lukas
nachgemacht fühlt ihr euch jetzt cool
kultiger schickte mir video fordert eine
autobahn
warum ich zeig dir zeigen jetzt von mir
[Musik]
das war das war wieder sehr sehr kurz
leute wir nehmen das ganze video jetzt
mal ganz kurz unter die lupe also das
primäre ziel was diese zuschauer
eingeschaltet hat glaube ich mit dem
video ist mit der aufnahme dieser
verfolgt hat war dass diese person hier
eine kleine süßigkeit oder was auch
immer bei den mund geworfen bekommt
unterteil stolz hängt damit das ganze
irgendwie nach hinten los einerseits
können wir sagen dass die personen die
die süßigkeit fangen sollte mit dem mund
das ganze nicht geschafft hat
andererseits können wir allerdings auch
sagen dass dann danach die
zuschauerinnen weiter gefüllt hatte und
man dort gesehen hat wie ihre
sitznachbarin ihr getränk verschüttet
hat
[Musik]
der preis für die bisher jüngste 1
sendung jedoch jeden fall an euch freut
euch über eure dummheit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warum schickt dir dein video hier
schwimmt ich würde jetzt nicht auch noch
ein video wie ich schwimme aber so klar
ich kann schon schwimmen aber ich kann
halt nicht
ich weiß nicht wie das genau heißen ich
glaub butterfly schmetterlingen
schwingen ist schlimm schwingen
wahrscheinlich butterfly schwingen luca
genau also an dich zu schauen ich mir
das ein gesendet hat ich weiß nicht ob
das im wettkampf gewonnen wenn mich dann
weiter schwimmen schwimmer an die macht
was mache ich hier
das war somit das am besten geschäfte
video was ich je was möchte ich mein
wenn sie weg ist doch getroffen hätte
und dann den verbraucher und hätte aber
die hf sind nicht den basketballkorb
getroffen zweitens hat die danach
einfach auf ihr handy wieder drauf
gedrückt und da dann die nächste
aufnahme gestartet
ist das dein ernst du schickst du mich
video wie du dir fünfter zehnter oder
direkt
[Musik]
b
danke an danke dass ihr somit die erste
einblendung wirklich irgendwie wir
zugeschickt wurde wo jemand wirklich
etwas kann um bevor wieder irgendjemand
in den kommentaren sauer auf mich ist
nein ich sehe leute die irgendwie cool
schmetterling schwimmen können oder
arbeiten sie alles machen können nicht
als talentlosen aber das hier will ich
eine klasse sache klavier spielen
in ramsthal bisher da will ich dann die
wahl noch wenige sich über die haare
frühjahres zumindest
fährt ein pferd aus einer plastiktüte
schlüssel ich verstehe nicht was die
leute sich bei ihnen einbildungen denken
die denken sie sich doch dann nicht
irgendwie sowas wie alle locker machten
video war unsere video nicht film fährt
nicht aus petra packung trink heirat der
rest entsteht wenn nicht mehr wo man
während kommen aber noch kinder
freut euch jetzt wie zu beginn
angekündigt
die weiteren block ausschnitte die ich
im urlaub gefilmt habe zeigen werde ganz
kurz damals luca reagiert das ganze ist
nicht böse gemeint also ich denke dass
dieses format darauf aufgebaut ist
nämlich nicht über videos von meinen
zuschauern luft ich mache und das kam
mir sehr viel an und ich wollte diesmal
nicht so viel nehmen werde einfach aus
dem grund weil ich ja die türken schon
gesagt jetzt noch eben euch die locker
schnitt auf dem urlaub noch zwei gebäude
und mit euch lassen wollte weil die
letzten fünf sechs tagen noch nicht so
wirklich aktiv war und halt mehr oder
weniger im urlaub aber ich zeige euch
jetzt erstmal ein paar ausschnitte die
ich noch im urlaub gefilmt habe
allerdings noch nicht in block
reingepackt habe und auch nicht mehr
machen wollte weil halt wegen solcher
band winter rapid aber ich hab noch ein
paar sachen gefüllt ich eigentlich
wirklich wahr so here you go machst du
gut ich habe gerade auf twitter gepostet
dass ich mit dem fragen stellen deswegen
wird mir feststellen
der erste frage von melanie bist du dumm
korrekt fragt hast du hase auf deiner
bus alles klar wir haben ja eine
philosophin dieser biologischen zwar
möchte sie gerne von ihr wissen und
warum ist die banane krumm ok lana haben
möchte dann kannst du mal ein bisschen
schwieriger für uns machen
ich dachte ich wirklich was passiert
[Applaus]
gerade die blatt papier geschenkt auf
dem man versteht bett youtuber er war
kann ich auf jeden fall recht geben
meine leser luca auf instagram darf
herzlich begrüßt sich heute zu einer
neuen blog kategorien wahrheit die
kategorie stelle meine fragen
beantwortet oder der luca 2 millionen
euro los geht das ist jetzt durch zwei
die ersten zwei millionen euro nach
deutschland
die würze würde einen mittagsschlaf
beurteilen oder gut hier mit den kabeln
elektrisiert sich halter laufen die
gerade in so einen komischen weg lang
und die freundschafts klingt das jetzt
gerade quasi eingebettet gesehen habt
waren noch ein paar aufnahmen die ich
übrig hatte die ich ja wie ich schon
tausendmal gesagt habe ich wollte
eigentlich den urlaub nutzen um mit ein
paar freunden lustige blogs verdrehen
bisschen spaß da gleichzeitig auch ein
bisschen runter zu kommen vom uni stress
cetera pp
allerdings waren wirklich dort wo wir
waren sehr sehr viele versicherungen
teilweise bis auf erfolg haben und dann
haben wir eine gruppe gesagt der luca
das kommt halt ein bisschen durch seine
blogs und ich habe mir selber gesagt ja
kommen
dann braucht ihr den block die macher
jetzt ein paar tage kein video
vielleicht noch normales video was ja
dann auch gemacht habe ich aus diesen
büchern vorgelesen haben bei sturm im
film
aber dafür auf jeden fall der grund
warum während der letzten tage halt
nicht so viele block aus dem urlaub
kamen sondern halt nur zwei stück von
den fünf tagen und ich hatte halt wie
gesagt noch ein bisschen weiter gefilmt
aber ein paar lustige szenen wollte
einfach meinen wänden und jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz zu der sache bezüglich dem
lukas ott lounge wir eventuell wildnis
am ersten wecken also wenn ihr das video
sieht vor fünf tagen um 15 uhr neue shop
gelangen zu dem zeitpunkt war ich gerade
wobei ich doch auf der fähre glaube ich
also auf dem wasser nicht am land wo gut
das internet war und die stadt die ganze
zeit den kontakt wird den leuten von
lukas shop also mit werden die mit
stefanie mit vier leuten wieder
tagtäglich daran arbeiten das ganze
super gut funktioniert allerdings bei
einer wm mit enorm vielen leuten
dauerhaft auf der webseite nicht viel
weiß noch wie wir es immer waren aber
sehr sehr viele von euch anprobiert
davon zu bekommen andererseits war
vielleicht auch ein hacker angriffs oder
irgendwann cyber schild am start war mir
in dem moment an egal weisheit mit
meinen kollegen auf einer fähre waren
wir haben zeit auf den urlaub gefreut
allerdings für eine live-schaltung 15
uhr und auch um 19 uhr konnte man nicht
so richtig bestellen deswegen haben wir
den kompletten lounge verkauft weil
irgendwelche spaß die irgendwie als ich
mich server gehackt haben ich hab keine
ahnung also mir ist es egal wie es läuft
also ich wollte nur sagen dass es
deswegen paar komplikationen gab mich
auch mit der kommunikation nicht
bedeutend hergekommen weil ich halt im
urlaub war aber ihr könnt auf jeden fall
jetzt in denen ihr könnt ihr jetzt auf
jeden fall sachen kaufen wie gesagt es
ist nicht ausverkauft denn dass wir
dauerhaft weiter produziert also wenn
ihr euch das nochmal überlegen wollen
mit dem kaufen dann macht das gern aber
es sind
wer längere lieferzeiten gerade
vorhanden weil schon sehr sehr viel
gestellt wurde und die unterschriebenen
sticker sind meine ich auch schon alle
weg aber wie gesagt trainings in der
beschreibung also wenn ihr match kaufen
wollten auf jeden fall dort vorhanden
und ja da betten oder auch mal ganz kurz
als warum dieser launch pad mitte
perfekt war nicht so viele instagram
bilder markierungen bekommen und viele
twitter nachrichten und so viele leute
die mir hass entgegengebracht haben von
wegen eva ist das sind schreckliche tat
sich geständig auf die seite darauf ging
ja da kann ich nichts führt wir haben
extra viel geld in die hand genommen um
neue server anstatt trotzdem nicht
gebracht also ich will mich auch nicht
mit so viel scheiße negativen hier
beschäftigen aber jetzt geht auf jeden
fall kommen wir jetzt zur letzten sachen
über die ich ganz kurz reden wollen das
ist eine kombination aus lucka reagiert
block und intro video scheint in der tat
ich wollte euch kurz sagen was bei mir
gerade so abgeht und war deshalb vom
ersten wechsel bis zum wechsel wächst
bis heute wenn ihr das video den tag
sieht hochgeladen habe war ich im urlaub
das war chil in dieser gerade wenn der
video rauskommt dienstagmorgen muss
max nach berlin wegen der kooperation
das heißt morgen am mittwoch mich in
berlin fahre dann am
donnerstagnachmittag von berlin zurück
und am freitagmorgen fliege ich nach
münchen um münchen zwei stunden zu sein
und dann weiter nach elf zufrieden nach
amerika und ich wollte euch einfach
jetzt mal so ein bisschen auf dem
laufenden halten was denn überhaupt so
abgeht also in berlin bin ich halt wegen
der sache die ich so noch nicht sagen
darf aber im leben ich wegen der e3 bzw
eigentlich sogar vielmehr wegen der ea
play ich weiß nicht wie viel ich zu dem
thema zu sagen kann da kommen auf jeden
fall mega krasse sachen und ich werde
ihn auch ab und zu blocken ich werde mit
meinem manager hinfliegen und wir werden
dort auch und entspannte zeit haben weil
er teilt auch ein freund von mir obwohl
er halt irgendwie total auf vollidiot
ist auf jeden fall wollte ich nur ganz
kurz sagen freunde
wenn in den nächsten neun tagen videos
nicht regelmäßig vom oder teilweise mal
um 11 uhr morgens oder mal irgendwie um
21 abend bitte verzeiht mir das liegt
einfach daran dass ich gerade irgendwie
berlin münchen oder keine ahnung wo auch
immer wenn ich versuche täglichen video
heraus zu hause auch mein wissen an mich
selbst und ich denke das werde ich
irgendwie schon hinkriegen ich wollte
sagen dass dort auf jeden fall der fall
sein wird und ich werde auch noch
zwischenzeitlich wahrscheinlich ist es
kurz sein ich habe auch alles scheißegal
ich wollte erst heute werk ein video
machen weil ich wie gesagt heute aus dem
urlaub zurück gefahren wenn ich dann mit
langen staus war noch kaputt das hat
mich glaube ich alles bei instagram
gesehen marder hat ihnen der leitung
durchgefressen auf jeden fall war dann
letztendlich irgendwie sieben stunden
unterwegs ist gerade 20 uhr ich bin
jetzt zu hause angekommen in elf stunden
geht schon wieder meinen zug berlin aber
ich habe mir einfach gedacht ich muss
das mal einfach alles erzählen was bei
mir abgeben weil es ja auch dumm wenn
ich euch im schatten stehen lassen ich
bin ja irgendwie ne verbundene personen
des öffentlichen interesses keine
persönlicher oder hab ich mir gedacht
ich verbinde das ist einfach damit dass
ich kurz luca reagiert einfüge und
außerdem noch ein paar flocken
ausschnitte zeigen hey wer dieses video
vielleicht dort nun gefeiert werden live
freuen uns tut mir leid jetzt lange über
infos geladen habe hier findet jetzt
hier oben gewählt wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren darum bin ich
doch mein job eingeblendet in dem wie
gesagt man tagen die neue kollektion
lounges und hier unten ist ein weiteres
video verlinkt und bitte vergeben für
die nächsten tage wenn ich ein bisschen
unregelmäßig hochladen